they're now safe
but their journey to poland was all the
more traumatic because dennis is
completely blind and olga has one
percent vision
really relieved because it was a bit of
a nightmare
it was daughter inga's fifth birthday
when russia invaded ukraine when um the
sounds of war
became very close which is on the
probably on the second or on the third
day
that i decided that we really have to go
but i was not sure about the way how to
arrange it
taking a bus or a train was impossible
five cats and two dogs that makes like
seven
cages right and then there is a child
whom we have to control
and we cannot do it visually so
basically we have to keep her by the
hand especially at the railway station
in these circumstances right when it's
crowdy
a stranger offered to drive them to the
border the journey took two days and
olga is nearly six months pregnant
i i don't know who i worried more at
that moment about my child who is five
or about my
child who is still in in my stomach i
just knew i had to survive this journey
but still you were driving through a war
zone right
of course it was like a little scary
because you never know what moment and
from what side
something may fly into your car
the family are staying in an apartment
provided by a well-wisher
there are some people who are who can
manage somehow themselves and there are
some people who really need
assistance you need help
but their life has been turned upside
down it's a strange new world in every
sense
and all the more difficult because
dennis's russian relatives can't
understand why they've put themselves
through this
they say well you just do not understand
just go ahead and drink some water and
calm down i said well i will come down
as soon as
your troops stop bombing my my village
until the war ends a community on the
outskirts of warsaw is doing their best
to make them feel at home
lisa holland sky news warsaw